>> Sean: MIKE FROM CHICAGO
TONIGHT, THANK YOU.
WE WILL BRING UPDATES FROM THOSE
PROTESTS ALL NIGHT TONIGHT.
DESPITE THE HYSTERIA ON THE LEFT
OF THE SUPREME COURT RULING WAS
A MOMENTOUS DECISION THAT
RETURNS ABORTION LAW BACK TO THE
STATES WHERE IT BELONGS, AS IT
IS NOT ENUMERATED IN THE
CONSTITUTION LIKE THE RIGHT TO
KEEP AND BEAR ARMS, WHICH WE
DISCUSSED AT LENGTH LAST NIGHT.
SOME STATES WITH THE MOST
LIBERAL ABORTION LAWS THAT EVEN
ALLOW THIRD TRIMESTER ABORTIONS,
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR MAP OR THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO ALLOW THEM.
THAT WILL INCLUDE ALASKA,
COLORADO, NEW JERSEY,
NEW MEXICO, OREGON, VERMONT,
WASHINGTON, D.C.
WHILE DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA MOB
ARE PREDICTABLY DEMAGOGY AND
LYING ABOUT THIS VERY RULING, WE
WILL GIVE YOU THE FACTS STRAIGHT
UP AND LET YOU DECIDE.
LET US BE VERY CLEAR, THIS
DECISION DOES NOT MAKE ABORTION
IN AMERICA ILLEGAL.
IT DOES NOT.
I KNOW THEY ARE IMPLYING THAT,
THEY ARE SAYING IT EVEN BUT IT
DOES NOT.
INSTEAD, INDIVIDUAL VOTERS, YOU
WILL NOW DECIDE ABORTION LAW AT
THE STATE LEVEL PER THE TENTH
AMENDMENT OF OUR CONSTITUTION.
REMEMBER, POWERS THAT ARE NOT
ENUMERATED IN THE CONSTITUTION
LIKE THE RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR
ARMS ARE RESERVED FOR THE
STATES.
IN LIBERAL STATES THERE WILL BE
FEW IF ANY RESTRICTIONS ON
ABORTIONS, IN SOME CASE UNTIL
BIRTH.
SOME STATES WILL CONTINUE TO
ALLOW ABORTION ON SOME LEVEL PER
THERE MIGHT BE SOME RESTRICTIONS
IN SOME STATES AND DIFFERENT
ONES IN DIFFERENT STATES.
HERE IS THE SECOND FACT ABOUT
THIS REALLY COME ABORTION WAS
NEVER ENSHRINED IN THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION AS A RIGHT AND
IT WAS NEVER CODIFIED IN LAW.
INSTEAD IT BECAME THE STATUS QUO
FOR 50 YEARS BECAUSE OF ACTIVIST
JUDGES PRETENDING THEY WERE THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
COEQUAL BRANCHES, THEY ARE NOT
SOMETIMES.
AS GREGG JARRETT RIGHTLY POINTED
OUT IN A GREAT COLUMN ON
FoxNews.com, ROE V. WADE IS
JUST ONE OF MORE THAN MORE THAN
230 TIMES THE COURT HAS
OVERRULED THIS PRECIOUS
PRECEDENT THAT WE OFTEN HEAR
DEMOCRATS TALKING ABOUT.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE
PLESSY V. FERGUSON.
THAT IS WHAT LEGALIZED
SEGREGATION.
THAT PRECEDENT WAS DONE AWAY
WITH, RIGHTLY SO.
IN THE AWFUL DREAD SCOTT
DECISION THAT UPHELD SLAVERY.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
ANOTHER WAS OVERTURNING
PRESIDENT IS NOT UNCOMMON AND IN
MANY PLACES AS WE JUST
DESCRIBED, THE RIGHT THING TO D.
NATURALLY ROE V. WADE WAS ALWAYS
AT THE MERCY OF THE COURTS BUT
DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT.
LISTEN TO FAR LEFT HERO OF THE
LEFT, SOCIALIST HERSELF, JUSTICE
RUTH BADER GINSBURG.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> ROE BECAME A SYMBOL, I THINK,
FOR THE RIGHT TO LIFE MOVEMENT.
THEY HAD A SINGLE CAUSE.
THIS DECISION THEY SAID, THIS
MOST UNDEMOCRATIC DECISION
BY NINE JUSTICES NOBODY ELECTED
TO MAKE POLICY FOR THE COUNTRY,
MY CRITICISM OF ROE IS IT SEEMED
TO HAVE STOPPED THE MOMENTUM,
THE MOMENTUM WASN'T ON THE SIDE
OF CHANGE.
>> Sean: RUTH BADER GINSBURG'S
PREDICTION HAS COME TRUE.
SHE WAS RIGHT, ROE IS NOW
OVERTURNED AND THIS BRINGS US TO
THE THIRD FACT ABOUT TODAY'S
ROOM AND GET THE COURT'S
DECISION TODAY IS ABOUT ABORTION
AND ABORTION ALONE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT CONTRACEPTION,
IT'S NOT ABOUT GAY RIGHTS, IT'S
NOT ABOUT INTERRACIAL MARRIAGES
MANY HAVE BEEN SUGGESTING AND
LYING ABOUT.
THE MAJORITY OPINION MAKES THIS
QUITE CLEAR.
"TO ENSURE THAT OUR DECISION IS
NOT MISUNDERSTOOD OR
MISCHARACTERIZED, WE EMPHASIZE
OUR DECISION CONCERNS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION AND NO OTHER RIGHTS.
NOTHING IN THIS OPINION SHOULD
BE UNDERSTOOD TO CAST OUT ON
PRECEDENTS THAT DO NOT CONCERN
ABORTION.
NATURALLY THE MEDIA MOB, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE CONVENIENTLY
IGNORING THE TRUTH, THE FACTS,
THE TEXT AND THE RULING.
WHY LET TRUTH GET IN THE WAY OF
A GREAT POLITICAL NARRATIVE?
SORT OF LIKE JANUARY 6TH, THEY
WANT TO USE ABORTION, JUST LIKE
YESTERDAY'S SUPREME COURT RULING
ON THE SECOND AMENDMENT, AS A
WEDGE ISSUE TO FIRE UP THEIR
BASE IN THE HOPES THAT THEY MAY
MITIGATE THE PENDING LOSSES THAT
MANY ARE PREDICTING.
ACCORDING TO THEM, AMERICA IS IN
PERIL ALL BECAUSE OF EVIL
REPUBLICANS AND OF COURSE
DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS AS DEVASTATING RULING
AS CAN BE IMAGINED.
>> THIS IS A COURT THAT HAS
UPENDED A HALF-CENTURY OF LAW OF
A CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT TO ABORTION THAT AFFECTS
NEARLY EVERY FAMILY ACROSS
AMERICA IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
>> IS A HEARTBREAKING BETRAYAL
OF HALF OF THE COUNTRY.
SORRY I'M GETTING -- WATCHING
THE WOMEN THERE, IT IS
EMOTIONAL.
>> NEW DEBATE OVER OTHER RIGHTS
WE THOUGHT WERE SETTLED.
THE RIGHT TO CONTRACEPTION, THE
RIGHT TO SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
ALL OF THOSE ARE THROWN INTO
QUESTION TODAY.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE A LEGAL
CIVIL WAR BETWEEN THE STATES.
>> THIS IS MONUMENTAL BECAUSE
IT'S THE FIRST TIME WE'VE SEEN
THE COURT TAKE AWAY A RIGHT.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE THIS IS A RIGGED COURT.
>> Sean: TOP DEMOCRATS WERE
JUST AS DRAMATIC AND EVEN MORE
SHAMELESS WITH A PLOY TO TURN
THIS RULING INTO VOTES IN
NOVEMBER.
TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> THIS FALL WE MUST ELECT MORE
SENATORS AND REPRESENTATIVES WHO
WILL CODIFY A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE INTO FEDERAL LAW ONCE
AGAIN.
ELECT MORE STATE LEADERS TO
PROTECT THIS RIGHT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
WE NEED TO RESTORE THE
PROTECTIONS OF ROE IS LOVE THE
LAND.
WE NEED TO ELECT OFFICIALS WHO
WILL DO THAT.
THIS FALL, ROE IS ON THE BALLOT.
PERSONAL FREEDOMS ARE ON THE
BALLOT.
>> BE AWARE OF THIS, THE
REPUBLICANS ARE PLOTTING A
NATIONWIDE ABORTION BAN.
IF THEY CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO
HAVE MAJORITY IN THE CONGRESS.
>> YOU HAVE THE POWER TO ELECT
LEADERS WHO WILL DEFEND AND
PROTECT YOUR RIGHTS.
AND AS THE PRESIDENT SAID
EARLIER TODAY, WITH YOUR VOTE
YOU HAVE THE FINAL WORD.
>> Sean: REMEMBER, THEY CAN'T
RUN ON THE GREAT STATE OF THE
ECONOMY BECAUSE WE HAVE A 41
YEAR HIGH OF INFLATION.
THEY CAN'T RUN ON GAS PRICES
BECAUSE WE SET A RECORD RECORD
AFTER RECORD AND ITS STILL GOING
HIGHER.
THEY CAN'T RUN ON THEIR FOREIGN
POLICY, THEY CAN'T RUN ON THE
DAMAGE THEY'VE DONE TO OUR
BORDERS, BUT THIS IS WHAT THEY
ARE GOING TO RUN ON.
THEY ARE TELEGRAPHING IT, THEY
ARE SAYING IT, BEING QUITE CLEAR
WHERE THEY ARE HEADED WITH THIS
AND IT GETS WORSE.
HILLARY CLINTON TWEETED TODAY
THAT TODAY'S OPINION WILL LIVE
IN INFAMY.
MEANWHILE NANCY PELOSI FOLLOWED
UP HER RANT ABOUT THE ELECTION
WITH A DRAMATIC READING OF THE
POEM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FROM TIME TO TIME I QUOTE
THIS POEM.
HERE IS MY HOME, I WILL NOT BE
SILENT, FOR MY COUNTRY HAS
CHANGED HER FACE.
MY COUNTRY HAS CHANGED HER FACE.
I SHALL NOT GIVE UP ON HER.
I SHALL REMIND HER AND SINGING
TO HER EARS UNTIL SHE OPENS HER
EYES.
CLEARLY, WE HOPE THAT THE
SUPREME COURT WOULD OPEN ITS
EYES.
>> Sean: PELOSI SPEAKER IN
NAME ONLY BUT THE REAL SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WAS
EVEN MORE DISTRAUGHT TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
CHOSE TO ENDANGER THE LIVES OF
ALL WOMEN AND ALL BIRTHING
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
BUT NOT ONLY THAT, THEY HAVE
CHOSEN TO STRIP RATES FROM MEN
TOO, BECAUSE FRANKLY THE
RIGHT TO OUR OWN BODIES AND THE
RIGHTS TO FORM FAMILIES, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT BELONGS TO ALL OF
US.
>> Sean: SHE WENT ON TO
PREDICT THAT PEOPLE WILL DIE
BECAUSE OF THE COURT'S DECISION
AND EVEN JOINED THE PROTEST
OUTSIDE OF THE SUPREME COURT,
CALLING FOR PEOPLE TO TAKE TO
THE STREETS.
AT THE SAME DEMONSTRATION HER
COMRADE MAXINE WATERS CALLED FOR
INSURRECTION AGAINST THE COURT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU AIN'T SEEN NOTHING YET.
WOMEN ARE GOING TO CONTROL THEIR
BODIES NO MATTER HOW THEY TRY
AND STOP US.
TO HELL THE SUPREME COURT.
WE WILL DECIDE THEM.
WOMEN WILL BE IN CONTROL OF
THEIR BODIES.
>> Sean: THANKFULLY THERE ARE
FENCES AND HEAVILY ARMED GUARDS
AT THE COURT.
THEY ARE THERE FOR A REASON.
EVER SINCE THE MAJORITY OPINION
WAS LEAKED THE JUSTICE HAVE BEEN
TARGETED WITH HARASSMENT,
THREATS OF VIOLENCE AND BY THE
WAY, NO CONDEMNATION FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
JOE BIDEN, PRESS SECRETARY,
OTHER DEMOCRATS, THEIR ADDRESSES
HAVE BEEN PUBLISHED ONLINE.
PROTESTERS SHOWING UP AT THEIR
HOME, A MAN TRAVELING FROM
CALIFORNIA TO THE FRONT DOOR OF
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH IN WHAT WAS
ATTEMPTED ASSASSINATION.
AMY CONEY BARRETT, THE NAME OF
HER KID'S SCHOOL AND LOCATION OF
THE CHURCH SHE GOES TO END THE
TIME SHE GOES TO CHURCH.
RADICALS HAVE VANDALIZED DOZENS
OF ANTIABORTION PREGNANCY
CENTERS ALL ACROSS THE U.S.,
BREAKING WINDOWS, LIGHTING
FIRES, SPRAY-PAINTED IN THE
MESSAGE "IF ABORTIONS ARE TO
SAFE, THEN NEITHER ARE YOU."
NOW A MILITANT GROUP NAMED JAMES
REVENGE THE TOOK CREDIT FOR MANY
OF THESE ATTACKS IS CALLING FOR
TONIGHT TO BE A NIGHT AND A
SUMMER OF RAGE.
THE GROUP DECLARED OPEN SEASON
ON PRO-LIFE AMERICANS, CLAIMING
THAT IT WAS FUN AND EASY TO
ATTACK CONSERVATIVES.
EVEN HINTED AT FUTURE ATTACKS
THAT MIGHT BE MUCH WORSE THAN
FIRE AND GRAFFITI AND YET MAXINE
WATERS, THE DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA
MOB ARE NOT CALLING FOR CALM,
INSTEAD WHIPPING THEIR RADICAL
SUPPORTERS INTO A FRENZY
TONIGHT, ALMOST AS IF THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY RESPECT OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND LET'S NOT
FORGET IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF WAS VERY MUCH
AGAINST ABORTION, TAKE A LOOK.
>> TELL ME ABOUT ABORTION, WHERE
DO YOU STAND AND HOW WILL YOU
FACE THAT ISSUE?
>> IT IS GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT.
I